sadly 2020 is another busy year for the
tensile town obituaries
from founding fathers of comedy and
veteran character actors
to up-and-coming stars that never got a
chance to truly shine
here are the actors we lost in 2020 not
yet covered on looper
former child actor jason davis died in
february 2020 of a fentanyl overdose
according to the l.a county medical
examiner
he was 35. jason made his debut in the
cbs sitcom dave's world at age
10 and would go on to appear in the
chris farley flop beverly hills ninja
as well as the jackie chan chris tucker
smash hit
rush hour while he was still a child but
his biggest role by far was mikey
bloomberg in recess
jason voiced the animated gentle giant
hundreds of times between
1997 and 2003. the young voices training
program doesn't like the word camp
they provide opportunities for aspiring
singers to train their voices in a
rigorous yet supportive setting
shortly after being arrested for
possession in 2011
jason appeared on vh1's celebrity rehab
and opened up about his quote
scary battle with heroin addiction he
survived by his brothers brandon and
alexander
and two half-sisters isabella and
mariella rickel
native mark bloom who starred opposite
madonna in desperately seeking susan and
played paul hogan's love rival in
crocodile dundee
passed away in march 2020. the stage and
screen actor died after complications
from covid19 he was 69.
younger viewers are more likely to
recognize bloom as either union bob
the piccolo player in amazon's classical
music comedy drama mozart in the jungle
or mr mooney the bookstore owner in
netflix's popular stalker show
you bloom's final role was dr mark
ruttenberg
a one-off character in showtime's hit
legal series billions
he's survived by his wife actress janet
zarish
john callahan the soap opera star who
played edmund gray on all my children
from 1992-2005
died in march 2020. according to
people's sources
callahan suffered a massive stroke and
did not recover
he was 66. callahan married eva leroux
in 1996
and the all my children colleagues had a
daughter named cara together before
divorcing in 2004.
callahan is also survived by two
stepchildren from his previous marriage
to linda freeman
callahan also appeared in over 100
episodes of days of our lives
other notable credits include falcon
crest santa barbara
desperate housewives and the bay british
actress
honor blackman who appeared opposite
sean connery as the iconic bond girl
[ __ ] galore
in 1964's goldfinger passed away of
natural causes surrounded by family
in april 2020 she was 94. blackman rose
to prominence in the early 1960s playing
leatherclad super spy kathy gale in the
avengers
the 60s secret agent tv comedy series
blackman carried on acting well
into her golden years but she became
better known for her activism and her
political career later in life
she was a card-carrying member of the
liberal democrats and would often speak
at party events
connecticut-born actor brian dennehy
best known for playing dogged small town
sheriff will teasel
in sylvester stallone's classic first
blood died of natural causes in april
2020.
he was 81. dennehy won a football
scholarship to colombia after leaving
the marines in 1963
and from there he got into yale where he
studied dramatic arts
after dozens of roles in tv and movies
he landed a recurring role on dynasty in
1981
and his career got another boost the
following year when he played john
rambo's nemesis
other notable appearances include ron
howard's sci-fi cocoon
and the lawrence cast in western
silverado both released in 1985.
dennehy made his overdue broadway debut
in the mid-90s and he would later voice
the character jango in the pixar hit
ratatouille
his final appearance was on a 2019
episode of nbc's the blacklist
film and tv actor dimitri dichinko best
known for his turn as
reckless tour guide yuri in the nuclear
horror chernobyl diaries
passed away in april 2020. dichenko who
was a first generation american of
ukrainian
swedish and greek heritage died suddenly
at his home in florida while
recovering from being electrocuted on
the job his agent confirmed
he was 52. dichenko appeared as a
russian enforcer in
indiana jones and the kingdom of the
crystal skull and
get smart and he played a similar role
in sons of anarchy
he has numerous other tv and movie
credits both on screen and
as a voice actor bollywood star irfin
khan
best known to western audiences for his
turns in jurassic world
life of pi slumdog millionaire and the
amazing spider-man
died in april 2020. the indian actor
suffered from a rare neuroendocrine
tumor in 2018
and later succumbed to an infection he
was 53.
khan was born in the northern state of
rajasthan he got his start on indian tv
and quickly made the transition to
feature length films he is survived by
his wife sutapa
and his sons babil and iron actor and
comedian jerry stiller passed away from
natural causes in may 2020 his son
hollywood star ben stiller confirmed his
death on twitter
stiller was 92. stiller made his
broadway debut in 1954
appearing in the musical comedy the
golden apple and his comedy act with
wife anne mira was popular throughout
the 60s and beyond
stiller had roles on tv sitcoms in the
70s and 80s and in the 90s began his
lengthy stint on seinfeld
and later the king of queens when my
blood pressure gets too high
the man on the tape tells me to say
serenity now
are you supposed to yell it and
undertake wasn't specific
stiller also popped up in many of his
son's movies over the years
most notably 2001's zoolander he also
appeared in the sequel
2016's zoolander 2 which was his last
feature film
california native nya rivera best known
for playing cheerleader santana lopez on
the smash hit musical comedy drama
series glee
died in july 2020. the singer and actor
went boating on lake pairu with her
four-year-old son
josie and never returned a search was
initiated when josie was spotted alone
on the boat
and rivera's body was discovered a few
days later the ventura county sheriff's
department called it a tragic accident
rivera was 33. rivera started out as a
child actor
making her debut on the cbs sitcom the
royal family at the age of four
she appeared on numerous tv shows before
glee creator ryan murphy cast her in
what would become her career defining
role
ohio-born actor fred willard best known
for his numerous collaborations with
actor and filmmaker christopher guest
died of natural causes in may 2020 he
was 86.
willard got started in sketch comedy in
1965
and played jerry hubbard on the parody
talk show fernwood tonight
his memorable short appearance in 1984's
this is spinal tap began his fruitful
relationship with guest
which would lead to roles in waiting for
guffman best in show
a mighty wind and for your consideration
willard was a four-time
emmy nominee he passed away just weeks
before the premiere of the netflix
series space force
his final role singer and actor chris
truesdale passed away in june 2020 from
complications from covet kovat19
he was 34. truesdale achieved broadway
prominence in les miserables
and in the boy band dream street many tv
appearances followed on shows like
lucifer and days of our lives
his final performance has him starring
as a wedding singer and the recently
released indie romance flick
new york christmas morning british
character actor ian holm
who played android ash an alien and
brought bilbo baggins to life in peter
jackson's the lord of the rings trilogy
passed away from a parkinson's related
illness in june 2020.
he was 88. i need a holiday
a very long holiday and i don't expect i
shall return
home was among the first group of actors
recruited to the royal shakespeare
company
upon its founding in 1961. in the
decades that followed he became a
celebrated fixture in british and
american theater at the highest levels
he was nominated for best supporting
actor in 1981 for his role in chariots
of fire
he played napoleon bonaparte in terry
gilliam's time bandits that same year
prominent parts followed in brazil
another woman and the fifth element
before holm
debuted as the adventurous hobbit bilbo
baggins
his most iconic role two-time oscar
nominee shirley knight who recurred on
desperate housewives and appeared in the
paul blart mall cop movies
died in april 2020 aged 83. knight made
her tv debut in 1955
and by the early 60s was a household
name in hollywood
she was nominated for a best supporting
actress oscar for the dark at the top of
the stairs
and again in sweet bird of youth after a
successful theater stint
knight returned to the screen in the
poseidon adventure and followed this
with many tv appearances
winning three of eight emmy nominations
in the process her final emmy nod was in
2006
when she was recognized for her work as
phyllis vandecamp and desperate
housewives
knight was also the proud owner of a
tony award new york-born comedy legend
carl reiner creator of the dick van dyke
show
died in his beverly hills home
surrounded by family in june 2020.
his son hollywood director rob reiner
announced his passing to the world on
twitter
carl reiner was 98. reiner started
working in television
in 1948 and spent the majority of the
50s bouncing between television and the
movies
he wouldn't become a household name
until the 60s decade of the dick van
dyke show
other notable credits include fraser
house seinfeld
ally mcbeal mad about you and the
ocean's 11 films
reiner was also a talented voice actor
who played characters on bob's burgers
justice league action family guy
american dad
and toy story 4. canadian tv and
broadway actor nick cordero died of
covet 19 in july 2020.
he fought the virus for 95 days before
passing away at a hospital in los
angeles
cordero was 41. cordero had many theater
roles
achieving his first full broadway
production in 2012.
he played cheech in bullets over
broadway in 2014 picking up a tony
nomination for his work in the jukebox
musical
the ontario native has also worked on
tv's queer as folk
lily hammer and law and order special
victims unit and in feature films a
stand-up guy and going in style
hollywood legend olivia de havilland the
last surviving star of 1939's gone with
the wind
passed away from natural causes in july
2020 at age 104.
during the classic film era de havilland
starred opposite arrow flynn
in no fewer than eight films though her
role as melanie and gone with the wind
was her most famous
the best picture winner is still
considered the most financially
successful
film of all time after inflation
adjustments de havilland went on to win
best actress statuettes for 1946's to
each his own
in 1949's the heiress japanese film and
tv star haruma mira
who starred in the live-action
adaptation attack on titan
died in july 2020 of a possible suicide
the actor was 30. meera was a former
child actor who worked in tv through his
teens
mira flitted between movies and
television in the decade that followed
receiving praise for his work in the
aviation epic the eternal zero
and soon after the two attack on titan
movies
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts
please call the national suicide
prevention lifeline at 1-800-273-talk
1-800-273-8255
mustachioed character actor wilford
brimley passed away in august 2020
after a struggle with diabetes and
kidney disease he was 85.
brimley made his big screen breakthrough
as a foreman in 1979's the china
syndrome
he impressed in sydney pollock's absence
of malice in 1981
worked under john carpenter in the
seminal sci-fi horror the thing in 1982
and starred as rejuvenated geriatric ben
luckett
in ron howard's cocoon in 1985. brimley
became a fixture on american television
in the 80s and 90s as the no-nonsense
quaker oats guy
and became a meme for his tv ads for
diabetes test strips
dame diana rigg bond girl tracy
davisenzo in on her majesty's secret
service
and alana tyrell in game of thrones
passed away in september 2020.
the acting legend was 82. it's a rare
enough thing
a man who lives up to his reputation
rigg began her career as a stage actor
in 1959
she made her screen debut that same year
in a made-for-tv version of a midsummer
night's dream
then became a household name as secret
agent m appeal
in the classic spy show the avengers now
a fashion icon in sex symbol
rig portrayed the only bond girl to
marry 07 in 1969.
returned to international prominence in
game of thrones and her final feature
film
edgar wright's last night in soho is set
to arrive in 2021
anglo-french actor michael lonsdale who
starred in the day of the jackal
and played bond villain hugo drax in
moonraker died in september 2020.
he was 89. lonsdale studied painting
before becoming an actor
making his stage debut at the age of 24
and his first
screen appearances in the 1950s
following blockbuster roles in the 70s
he would go on to appear alongside
robert de niro and jean reno in the 1998
action flick ronin
and later played the character papa in
steven spielberg's historical thriller
munich in 2005.
blonsdale's final film was the 2016
sci-fi
sculpt singer and actress helen reddy
who became synonymous with the feminist
movement and appeared in the film's
airport 1975 and pete's dragon
died in september 2020. the australian
grammy winner was 78.
in her career reddy would record over a
dozen top 40 singles though she will
always be remembered for
i am woman her feminist anthem reddy
played sister ruth in airborne thriller
airport 1975 the year after winning her
first grammy
and in 1977 she took on the role of nora
in pete's dragon
notable tv credits include fantasy
island the jeffersons and diagnosis
murder
i am woman a biopic about reddy's rise
to stardom premiered just a month before
her death
actor clark middleton passed away in
october 2020 after suffering from west
nile virus
the veteran actor and disabilities
advocate was 63.
middleton lived with rheumatoid
arthritis for most of his life but he
never let it stop him from pursuing
his passion he made a stage debut in
1983 and developed into a dependable big
screen actor
middleton worked with quentin tarantino
on kill bill volume 2
ang lee in taking woodstock bong joon ho
in snow piercer
david lynch in twin peaks the return and
alejandro inarritu
and best picture winner birdman
middleton was also regularly seen on
many different tv shows
veteran actress and dancer marge
champion who starred in a series of
musicals opposite her husband in the
1950s
passed away in october 2020 at the age
of 101.
in the 1930s champion served as the
model for walt disney's titular
character in snow white and the seven
dwarfs
she also modeled the blue fairy in 1940s
pinocchio
hyacinth hippo in fantasia and mr stork
in dumbo
champion made her broadway debut in 1945
and would become a movie star the
following decade with a string of mgm
musicals
champion would later scoop an emmy award
for her choreography work on the
critically acclaimed 1975 telefilm
queen of the stardust ballroom sean
connery the scottish movie icon best
known for originating the role of james
bond on the big screen
died in october 2020 at age 90. connery
rose to prominence in 1961
in the bbc's anna karenina the former
model made his debut
as double 07 in dr no in 1963.
connery became a globally recognized
star and his influence grew with every
subsequent installment
connery appeared in eight bond films in
total i admire your luck
mister bond
james bond post bond connery appeared in
films like highlander the untouchables
indiana jones in the last crusade the
hunt for red october and the rock
actor eddie hassell who played clay in
the best picture nominee the kids are
all right
and apple employee chris espinoza in
jobs
died in november 2020. hassel was
fatally wounded in a robbery gone
tragically wrong
he was 30. hassell landed his first
significant role in 2005
securing the part of phil nance in the
lake bell bell-lead
sci-fi series surface which led to more
prominent roles in film
castle was also known for devious maids
on which he recurred as the wrongfully
convicted eddie suarez
bert belasco best known for playing
charles whitmore in the bet sitcom let's
stay together
passed away in november 2020. velasco
was pronounced
dead at a hotel in virginia of a likely
aneurysm
according to his father's report to tmz
he was 38.
after early work and improv and video
game vocal performance velasco appeared
in an episode of house
he went on to become a regular on
american tv recurring on the baseball
dramedy pitch and the jim carrey
produced i'm dying up here
other notable appearances include
justified key and peel
ncis new orleans and american princess
though belasco will undoubtedly be
remembered for his 52-episode stint on
let's stay together
star of the stage and screen laurence
clayton who made his broadway debut as
part of the replacement cast of dream
girls
died in november 2020 after a battle
with cancer he was 64.
clayton was a regular in new york's
theater scene he made his bow with cc
white and dream girls in 1981 and went
on to appear in a number of other
broadway musicals
he appeared in the 2015 revival of the
color purple
and the oprah winfrey produced show won
the tony award for best revival of a
musical
clayton also toured with productions of
jesus christ superstar and les
miserables during his days on the stage
as for tv clayton made his screen debut
in the 1989 episode of the equalizer
later appearing on deadline law order
criminal intent
as the world turns the big c homeland
law and order special victims unit
and the cbs sherlock holmes show
elementary clayton made his final
appearance in a 2019 episode of
netflix's groundbreaking
lgbtq drama pose compton native
tommy tiny lister best known for playing
neighborhood bully debo
in the friday films passed away in
december 2020
the actor and former wrestler was found
unresponsive at his california apartment
variety confirmed
after reporting covet 19 like symptoms
lister was 62.
lister was a prolific character actor
who had well over 200
credits to his name when he died he made
his debut as a football player in a 1984
episode of the abc sitcom webster
and would have a stint in professional
wrestling before establishing himself as
a go-to tough guy in hollywood
he played a bail agent in quentin
tarantino's jackie brown
and a tattooed prisoner in christopher
nolan's the dark knight
but it was the role of debo that earned
him a place in pop culture history
harry haynes terry jones
stan kirsch norma michaels
huquis byrne david prowse
max von sydow janae dubois
kelly nakahara esther scott
nikita waligwa lynn cohen
kevin conway kirk douglas
jack kehoe kirby mora
john carlin trini lopez
marsha cramer william bogart raphael
coleman
conchata farrell elsa raven margaret
nolan
emilia mcqueen yuko takeuchi
sai ashina chadwick boseman
alan rich ash christian
ben cross rene centone
rhianna black annie ross
jacqueline scott john saxon
galen gorg kelly preston
earl cameron jill gascogne
tony scannell mel winkler
peggy pope geno silva mary pat gleeson
anthony james richard hurd
hagin mills gregory tyree boyce
john mayhan sam lloyd
bruce alpress jean danerski
jack wallace julie bennett
shirley douglas hilary heath
tom lester lee fierro
alan garfield logan williams
j benedict andrew jack
john shrapnel